some of the rarest creatures on the
planet have been captured by some of the
world's greatest photographers
international awards for wildlife
photography were just handed out in
london
announced by the duchess of cambridge
kate middleton through britain's
national history museum
roxanna saberi shows us some of the best
a monkey meditating a crocodile carrying
hundreds of its offspring
and a squirrel scurrying away from two
gazing
owls intimate moments in nature captured
for
all of us to see this is my favorite
category
animals in the environment roz kidman
cox led the judging of this year's
wildlife photographer of the year awards
choosing from nearly 50 000 entries from
around the world
they're complex pictures and you can
look at them again and again and see
more
look closely you'll see a hippo hiding
in the mud
and a lion peering through the grass
but these images now on display at
london's natural history museum and
online
are meant to do more than make you stop
and look
science director tim littlewood says
they're meant to make you stop
and think they are a spectacular
showcase to remind us that we
are part of nature and we are
desperately responsible for nature
he says this theme of our impact on
nature runs stronger this year than in
the previous five and a half decades of
the competition
take this image of a man slicing up bats
in an indonesian market
we know that markets such as this are a
hotbed for
diseases such as covid viruses that are
moving
from animals to humans and then there is
destruction
of the amazon those two images to me
are screaming both natural history and
and the human impact story other photos
tell a more subtle
story like this picture of puffins taken
by 14 year old evie easter brook off the
english coast
i know that they're quite endangered
because there are only certain areas
with the amount of fish they need to eat
you spend so matt moran watched for
wildlife closer to home
in london all you want to be thinking
about is composing
and firing the shutter this image really
worked for me um
because you have that incredibly intense
stare
with this female looking at her younger
brother saying you know there's no way
you're going to get this rat
back off yeah totally out of the 100
finalists
the duchess of cambridge cape middleton
announced the winner in an online
ceremony on thursday night this year's
wildlife photographer of the year
is
sergey goshkoff for his image the
embrace
what made this the winner well you can
see look at the color look at the light
it's a truly magical picture
it's a shot of a tiger an amore tiger
from the russian far east they've had
big poaching problems but
with protection the good news is that
tigers are increasing
the people behind these photos hope they
move us to do much more to protect our
beautiful planet
wake up everybody it's our home our
collective home
but reminding us we're all in this
together
for cbs this morning saturday roxanna
suberi
london gorgeous incredible how do you
pick one picture out of that right
they're all so incredible beautiful
shots it makes my pictures of my dog
upside down look like absolutely nothing
i got to work and you know i pride
myself on my ig posts but yeah i ain't
nothing
about that your ig posts are pretty
impressive yeah competition for that
yeah
michelle out into the water
is he teasing me